Bonjour à tous, bienvenue dans votre journal
Suite à la crise mondiale
Nous subissons une nouvelle hausse record du chômage avec 12 169 300 chômeurs supplémentaires
La spirale semble ne pas pouvoir s'arrêter
*musique dramatique*
Monsieur le premier ministre! Nous avons un problème
Le chômage explose le plancher, nous craignons des émeutes dans le pays d'une semaine à l'autre
Je sais!
On va créer des emplois d'hommes-objets
Ok!
Première mesure du gouvernement pour résorber ce chômage record : la création de 12 169 300 emplois d'hommes-objets
Pour mieux comprendre, regardons ensemble ce reportage de Jiluc Seychelle
Depuis la mise en vigueur de cette loi
des hommes-objets fleurissent dans toute la France
focus sur ces nouveaux emplois comme Thierry qui est GPS
Tournez à droite
Faites demi-tour c'est pas par là, c'est pas par là
Faites demi-tour
*tousse* demi-tour, fais demi-tour
fais demi-tour là
Sylvain, lui, a trouvé un poste de brosse à dents électrique chez un couple dans les Yvelines
Et enfin, voici Marc-Antoine qui était en recherche d'emplois depuis plus de 2 ans
Il peut finalement s'épanouir pleinement dans une activité de barre de métro
Le climat économique était tendu mais visiblement la courbe du chômage semble indiquer une baisse record
Du jamais vu en terme de croissance, un pic historique
Et Christian, le mari de ma sœur, lui, il est homme-cravate
Oh putain le taf de merde!
Si les promesses du gouvernement semblent avoir été tenues, ces mesures audacieuses ne cachent elles pas un autre problème
toc toc toc
Monsieur le premier ministre, nous avons encore un problème
Comme le chômage n'existe plus
les 45 000 employés du Pôle emploi...ils sont sans-emplois!
-Aaaaah!     -Pardon
Je sais!
On va fabriquer une machine à voyager dans le temps, on va faire un bond dans le passé
On va aller chercher les chômeurs d'il y a 2 mois et les ramener dans le présent
Ok!
Et donc la France est mystérieusement surpeuplée
Retour au chômage avec cette hausse record de 12 169 300 chômeurs
Malgré les mesures du gouvernement, la spirale semble ne jamais pouvoir s'arrêter
Voilà c'est la fin de ce journal, on se retrouve lundi, passez un bon week-end
Allez à lundi, Michel et surtout, tu soignes ton dos